[Music]
serious new seriousness guys recently
beaverton police
have taken a hamster into product
protective custody after the owner is
accused of a dui what
they took a hamster into protect because
the house was a [ __ ] rat
that's good bro that's looking good
that's looking good
he's a witness protection
rat
that's the best joke that's basically
just a punchline he made me laugh
he's a little smirk he just goes
he waited
he waited for us to get
go it yourself joe you just need to
rephrase that as the first half of a
joke you knew you knew that article was
coming no i haven't
that's just the name of the the video
hands were taken into protective custody
because it was a rat yeah
oh my gosh that's very good so three
three officers corral the hamster hold
the whole scenario three officers
corrupt town
this is some serious [ __ ] i told you
like it took three officers to take a
little hamster down oh he's a rat uh and
took the animal into protective custody
after the animal that's where he turned
into a rat and driver was accused of
impaired driving
so shortly after 12 30 a.m on tuesday
beaverton officer stopped this vehicle
on suspicion that the driver was
impaired they don't got crime there huh
in beaverton everybody's like super nice
right it's in beavers this is [ __ ]
rodent city right here dude
i got a favorite beavertail come on dude
lots of dams
damn specialties
wood damage everywhere dude
the rivers
[Laughter]
they took the [ __ ] hamster into
custody and that was like i ain't
telling you [ __ ] copper do you think
there's like a beaver mafia there that
was trying to kidnap the hamster of like
rodent supremacy there's like some
rodent turf war
there's the rats there's the beavers the
cops are actually gerbils your side of
the dam is over there yeah marsupials
highly outnumbered so uh
the officers reportedly talked with this
driver whom they identified as nicole
huey of 27 years old uh and found that
she had a hamster on her lap the hamster
whose name is unknown
sad to say was loose inside the vehicle
and was the only other occupant okay
huey reportedly told the police she was
headed to a local store
uh they told her to get out of the
vehicle and left the hamster she left
the hamster on the dashboard police
arrested her on accusation of driving
under the influence and then yes it took
three officers to corral this furry
little passenger they say
huey told the police that she didn't
have anyone who could get the hamster so
they should just kill it what what what
a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] that's why he's
like is that what she said well [ __ ]
that i'm telling you everything that
[ __ ] was drunk this [ __ ] was drinking
in the car i can't believe it if you
turn on an animal it's over if you turn
on an animal it's over i bet the jury
was like executor
give her the death penalty
you [ __ ] with an animal it's over you
get no human cement there's no human
sympathy and the hamster has to flip the
switch that's [ __ ] up man oh yeah
the switch is on the floor and the
hamster just runs around until it
happens
they put in them almost there almost
there
put some cheese on it i think it's a
wheel and it's generating the
electricity that's way better it's time
it's a slow kill
just a low voltage shock
and then once the hamster stops she's
like oh [ __ ] i'm out of the woods and it
doesn't here grab this fork we'll put it
into a socket while the hamsters run
or some statistic like the hamster's
little water bottle thing has a button
that once it like goes down it touches
the magnetic field on the bottom it just
kills a person so
as long as they hamster drinks that's
pretty creative i'm [ __ ] up yeah so uh
you want a science fair too
this is really messed up right it's like
no nobody's here to pick up the
handstand you could just kill it that's
[ __ ] up death penalty for sure
police told her that the pet would not
be harmed and they would take the pet to
a safe location petco
it's like a safe house
they're like we put it in uh we put it
in her and then one of them she's in wit
sack dude yeah they put it they put the
hamster in with sex they're taking that
to a snake witness protection
took three officers to capture you gotta
hide me coppers do you think they told
the hamster to freeze
like you know they drop freeze and they
pull their guns on their hands i feel
like your hamster's a victim so
everybody tastes it we're the good guys
oh they put they put a little blanket
over them and [ __ ] like the little
[ __ ]
the boyle ones
are you okay and then give them some
coke i'll tell you everything
sitting on the back of an ambulance just
waiting to get picked up
you think they breathalyze the hamster
as well it sounds like they didn't even
breathalyze her they were like i don't
know if she was drunk driving but they
put the [ __ ] oxygen thing over the
body
the whole hamster was sitting there
under the hospital he
[Laughter]
stuff
yeah
come on this [ __ ] uh furry little
passenger ends up going to the same spot
um they say when it took the three
officers
um time to capture the furry little
passenger they said it appeared that the
hamster wanted to stay in the vehicle
and it put up a good fight trying to
avoid capturing good fight
they [ __ ] [ __ ] abused this guy
they did it with the batons [ __ ] the
[ __ ] handcuffs smashed up the whole car
trying to beat them
do you think i just like did someone
just grab it i'm like imagining like do
they grab it what if they just what if
they just handcuffed it in one ring yeah
and just squeezed it just compressed its
body in like a hand that's right yeah it
just choked it like a key ring
but i think hamsters or i think mice
they can compress their skeletons that's
how they i wonder if hamsters call it
that's how they can flatten and fit
through things and stuff oh [ __ ]
what is the octopus
they've got some crazy animals man
they've evolved they've evolved to fight
us all dude everything is evolving to
fight humans
i will say anybody see documentaries i'm
like octopus yeah [ __ ] uh it's a pie
octopus my octopus teacher that's a good
one that's a good one i like that oh
that's the doctor that's the name of the
documentary yeah i think it won the
oscar yeah they're pretty smart but it's
also their fault that they're tasty
spoken like a japanese you know what you
know
i love resistance i love the part of my
octopus teacher where the the
marine biologist neglects his own family
to go hang out with an octopus
and his son is like i miss dad and he's
like i gotta go hang out
imagine if your son was like yo i miss
you daddy and you're like i'm gonna go
hang out with another see you later
when you can change color to the [ __ ]
surrounding environment then we'll talk
when you can blast ink in my face
i could blast something else
but it's a great documentary if you guys
haven't seen it it's really highly my
octopus teacher
it's [ __ ] highly recommended i heard
people stopped eating octopus after that
really i just got hungrier how many but
octopi is that is that correct octa peas
did i make did i make up that word i
think octopi is safer than octopussies i
know i like yours better i like the
[ __ ] don't call it mine but yes
we should take an internet poll yeah
let's just do it in the comments below
okay
but the real moral of this story that
was a bond this is this quoted from the
from the police up in beaverton
a lesson to learn from this incident
other than do not drink and drive
it is not safe to operate a motor
vehicle of any type with an animal on
your lap if they don't have enough crime
why don't they send some of those
[ __ ] down here yeah bring all
the hamsters here yeah get these
beaverton dudes over here yeah get some
cops over here you don't want to take
the criminals in the center of the
vehicle they won't i don't know
do you think they'll be able to handle
la
because we
what is the demographic of beaverton
just curious hamsters beavers
i watch super holes yeah
homo sapiens to marsupial percentage
it's just wondering and they got that
wasn't a racial question it was a
species question
they got the ferrets the illegal ones
you know badgers and [ __ ]
wild over there flying squirrels
ferrets are trained to steal jack rabbit
but what is the demographic of beaverton
a ton of beavers what state is it oregon
oregon oregon oh hard to say it's being
gentrified these days
full of gems today you're on he's on bro
he's killing it
earlier he got a lot of sodium in that
for lunch
that's what happens when you get enough
salt in your diet this is what it is
right here dude
first of all uh animals that are very uh
there's a new animal that they just
called sentient lobsters
yeah did everybody see this but they've
been doing that for a while they call
lobsters
i don't know who [ __ ] they is but uh
lobsters are now officially sentient so
you can't boil them alive so all the
chinese restaurants and everything like
that you can no longer boil imagine that
would stop them are you inhumane because
they feel the suffering and the pain you
gotta
cry you gotta kill them first they don't
have to kill them yeah they take
basically a knife just to the back of
the brain stem if you wanted to you know
but you know any more flavor away you
know any more aggressive brains boy you
always see it you see it on like
masterchef gordon ramsay like he doesn't
throw him in the pot of water he just
takes his knife you know but he makes it
look like a g like he'll spin his knife
like a samurai he's a
it's a fish
and it's dead see that's why you're a
voice actor i was [ __ ] sick dude i
feel like you were gordon ramsay right
there yeah
you're gonna take one and randy did you
guys see that
this is what we call acting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you